being inundated with
floodwaters.
You want to go up.
To keep that in mind.
That makes your safe place very
tricky on a day like today.
Here is a look.
Again, we do, I repeat that one
more time?
Monika, yes, I believe we do
have landfall.
They have just confirmed it.
We have landfall as of right
now.
The center of this storm has
officially crossed into Florida
as we speak, as a category
three storm near Keaton beach.
Repeating, we do have official
landfall near Keaton beach,
Florida.
As a category three storm.
Again, these impacts are going
to continue as this storm
continues to slide off to the
northeast.
Those outer bands are going to
continue to push very heavy
rain, every gusty winds, and
yes, that potential for some
tornadoes also exists across
the serious as well.
Back to you.
>> Thank you, Alison.
That was a really great update,
because we now know that
hurricane Idalia has hit
Florida, a direct here hit near
Keaton beach, Florida.
If you still have power and are
still watching television, this
is the time you take shelter.
You get into an area that is as
safe as possible inside.
Most places in Florida do not
have basements because the
water table is so high.
But get into a safe space at
higher grounds, try to stay
out.
To not get in your cars to.
Not try to leave now because
it's not the time for it in the
place like Eaton beach, where
hurricane Idalia, category
three storm, which means the
winds are sustained at 120
miles per hour or more.
Please, please, please do not
go out in this.
Don't play around with us,
because there will be
projectiles that will be
whipping around that could
really injure you and make some
serious damage to property.
All right, now that we know the
storm has hit there, what I can
tell you about some of the
other parts of Florida, the
shore has passed us by, but
look at what's happening.
You're still seeing these wind
gusts.
You're still seeing, because
there is a very powerful storm,
and you have the appalachians
of the storm that are still
very active here.
We are in crystal river,
probably more than 50 miles
away from where the storm is
hitting landfall, and yet,
there are still effects.
We are still seeing flooding.
We want to, we have now come up
about three feet because the
water has now come up several
feet from where we were
standing moments ago.
So, we are seeing some of that
storm surge.
It is the water that is going
to cost the greatest problems,
likely with this storm.
Especially now it is no longer
a category four storm.
Is the storm surge.
Please, for god's sake, be
safe.
Trying to get your pets, if you
have stayed inside, try to get
your pets into a safe spot as
well.
Let us go now to Derek van
damme.
He is in Tampa.
The storm has passed by, but
you would never know it,
because where he is.
It is inundated with water.
That storm surge having a
serious effect on Tampa.
Good >> Yeah, you know, Sarah,
with the national hurricane
center just calling landfall in
Keaton beach, this is the
strongest hurricane to impact
the big bend region and over
125 years.
Get this, folks.
This is the third land falling
hurricane in Florida in 12
months.
Wow.
What does that have to say
about people who try to ensure
their homes within this state,
that's a whole other topic.
But where I'm located, this is
bay shore, boulevard, and major
artery.
A thoroughfare for Tampa, which
is over my right shoulder.
I think that picture speak for
themselves.
This area has completely
flooded and it has and coached
on homes as well.
I'm going to have my camera man
just walk with me and tell
paint this picture, because the
surge is still coming in from
Tampa bay.
We checked one of the tidal
gauges.
Here, where we're located, it
is currently at record levels.
Five and a half feet of storm
surge near the title surge cage
that is closest to me.
What that is incredible.
Records go back to 1991.
So, we are in record territory,
and this is all looking
together, almost a
synchronicity of kind
cataclysmic events, right?
We have not only a powerful
major hurricane washing up the
water across the eastern
sections of the gulf of Mexico,
a very shallow water basin, by
the way, but we also have
inland flooding that is moving
from it, from the ground,
towards the ocean.
So, these working together in
conjunction, they meet in the
middle and they rise up the
water levels.
That is also being combined
with the impacts of a full moon,
which is a super moon, and that
has that great tidal swing.
With the highs and lows.
Even though you are nearing a
low tide in Tampa bay, we are
still getting the search and
the impacts from this storm
that is 200 miles away from us.
Just incredible.
Sarah?
What >> It is incredible.
I love what you just said
there.
That was very poetic.
A symphony of cataclysmic
events, all coming into
Florida.
We should mention, once again,
that hurricane Idalia has made
landfall in the big bend region
of the west coast of Florida.
It has made landfall.
It is hitting.
That means the eye is going to
be coming on to shore and then
those winds that rip around the
eye, that could be even more
devastating than the initial
winds, that is happening right
now.
You are looking at some live
pictures, and we want to show
you some satellite imagery to
that will all be coming up.
We're going to visit with